Salut la team Mentalo ! C'était une entrée tout en retournement pour fêter ce Lundi.
Aujourd'hui pas de vlog je vais vous parler des placements de produits et également des titres putaclic.
Il a écrit "Ultime" dans son titre, ça doit être un putaclic !
Est-ce que le fait que j'écris "putaclic" dans mon titre ça fait un titre putaclic du titre ?
La mise en abime du titre putaclic !
Je suis sur YouTube depuis peu de temps, depuis quelques mois à peine
Et j'ai donc découvert cet effervescence pour le titre putaclic.
C'est à dire que un titre putaclic, de base c'est une promesse qui est beaucoup trop forte par rapport au contenu
Est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on doit pas utiliser d'ironie dans les titres ?
Ou est-ce qu'on ne peut pas parler du thème de la vidéo dans le titre ?
La première fois qu'on m'a dit "Ah ça c'est un titre putaclic" c'est quand j'avais fais la vidéo sur Gilles Verdez et Joey Starr lors de la fameuse baffe
J'avais trouvé ça assez intéressant pour parler de la communication non violente, la CNV.
Récemment quand j'ai fais la vidéo sur le fait que j'allais me poser la question sur le fait de fermer la chaine ou pas
Est-ce que c'était un bon projet que de continuer à faire ce projet.
J'avais appelé la vidéo "Fermeture définitive"
Et bien croyez le ou non, avant que vous me disiez que c'est un "Putaclic", je pensais naïvement que c'était une bonne blague
Une belle ironie !
Tout ça pour vous dire que je ne vais pas me prendre la tête sur les titres d'une manière générale
Je vais mettre le titre que j'ai envie de mettre, je ne cherche pas si commercialement il est bon ou pas
Si c'est du "Putaclic" ou pas
Je veux juste que le titre corresponde à la vidéo et si je trouve un truc qui me fait marrer
Je mets le truc qui me fait marrer, ça va pas plus loin que ça ...
Mais parlons également des placements de produits !
Beaucoup de YouTubeurs en font parce que c'est un vrai moyen pour gagner sa vie
Pour financer ses projets YouTube
A ce jour je n'en ai jamais fais sur la chaîne
J'ai eu des propositions que j'ai refusé parce que je ne voyais pas l'intérêt
Ni artistique ni du produit par rapport à vous. Ou alors parce que la personne n'avait pas assez discuté avec moi
Je le vois comme ça : Je reçois une proposition de placement de produit
C'est pas sale. C'est pas la mal incarné ! Ca peut être hyper intéressant pour financer un projet pour la chaîne
Ou tout simplement pour rentabiliser un petit peu toutes ces vidéos.
Mais dans ces cas là j'estime que la personne en face doit vraiment connaître mon travail et la chaîne
Et doit vraiment discuter avec moi puisque j'ai beaucoup de demandes
Pour qu'on fasse un vrai projet de vidéo et non pas un placement de produit pur et dur.
Qui me permette de vous faire découvrir quelque chose, quelque chose d'intéressant, quelque chose de concernant
Et que moi aussi je prenne du plaisir dedans
Donc ça fait beaucoup de chose puisque que eux, leur priorité, c'est de respecter le produit qu'ils veulent placer
Mais sur YouTube vous vous demandez souvent si les gens font un placement de produit déguisé
Alors on va mettre les choses au clair dès aujourd'hui :
Quand je ferai un placement de produit, si un jour j'en fais, je vous le dirais tout simplement. Je vous l'annoncerez.
Ce qui veut dire qu'à chaque fois que j'ai parlais de sites internet, de livres, de films
De musiques ou de quoi que ce soit sur la chaîne je n'étais pas payer pour le faire
Et aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de deux sites internet qui sont mortels
Et je ne suis pas payé pour le faire
Je vais vous parler rapidement du Digithon. C'est un truc que je soutiens à mort
C'est une association qui a lancé un site internet qui s'appelle le digithon.fr
Il est porté par les deux sites internet les plus cool en ce moment : Lilo et Goodeed
Lilo c'est un moteur de recherche, je vous mets le lien dans le descriptif, qui s'appelle lilo.org
C'est un moteur de recherche vertueux
C'est à dire qu'à chaque fois que vous faites une recherche vous avez de la publicité, vous générez des revenus toujours
Eh bien là, la majorité des bénéfices que ça dégage partent pour des projets sociaux et des projets environnementaux
Et dans le même état d'esprit, même encore plus direct, y a Goodeed qui est un excellent
Excellent
EXCELLENT site
Ca vous permet de faire des dons à des oeuvres que vous choisissez
Non pas en faisant un virement bancaire si vous avez pas les moyens de le faire mais en regardant quelques vidéos
C'est comme si on vous rémunérez pour regarder les vidéos
Vous savez le modèle économique sur youtube : Vous regardez des vidéos, ça nous fait un petit peu de revenu
Quand je dis un petit peu je suis très au dessus de la vérité, j'en ai conscience
Eh bien là c'est à peu près la même forme sauf que votre argent vous savez où il va
C'est directement en don à des associations que vous sélectionnez
C'est pareil je vous mets le lien dans le descriptif !
Alors ces deux sites se sont rejoints pour ouvrir une association ensemble
Ils ont organisés donc le Digithon
La différence avec le Téléthon c'est qu'ici c'est que sur internet et que c'est entièrement gratuit
A aucun moment vous allez sortir le moindre cents !
Pour cette première édition le but du Digithon.fr est de réaliser le rêves de enfants malades
Nous allons le faire !
Alors nous, les YouTubeurs, je ne vais pas être le seul à en parler
Mais vous aussi vous pouvez participer en faisant vos recherches sur Lilo
Ou en visionnant les vidéos sur Goodeel
Pendant toute la durée du Digithon, qui est de 15 jours, tous les revenus qui vont être générés
Vont être donnés à l'association "Petit Prince" qui depuis 1987 réalise les rêves des enfants et des adolescents qui sont malades
Voilà c'est innovant, c'est gratuit, il n'y a pas besoin de donner de l'argent parce qu'on ne peut pas forcément tous donner de l'argent pour les dons
Officiellement ça commence aujourd'hui, ce 4 Juillet à 17 heures !
Si vous comptez participer en allant sur un des deux sites, ne serait-ce que quelques minutes
Faites le moi savoir en mettant un pouce en l'air
Ca nous permettra d'avoir une vraie vision du nombre de personnes du groupe "Team Mentalo" qui va participer au Digithon
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout !
Pour vous récompenser je vous donne quelques exclus sur cette semaine :
Demain je vais mentaliser Yacine Belhousse
Mercredi je vous parle du mensonge, des personnes qui vous mentent
Ca sera la deuxième vidéo que je ferai la dessus
Y en avait déjà une c'était la 90
Passez une excellente journée, abonnez vous avant de partir et rendez-vous demain à 17h
Tchao !